so I'm always going to appeal as much as
much as I possibly can to Iraq right so
3x minus 5 was it what we look like to
get at the absolute value so for a
second you can see grading you can see
the what is it so it will be something
like this one like that okay but of
course the absolute value mean it's
going to rebound like so the intercept
used to be w5 down here but that time
you [ __ ] it up so that makes that five
if you have a look at the gradient
that's good to go that's going to be
about was that three bits yeah it's okay
so you've got a rough picture now I want
to know when that thing is going to be
equal to two what Muslims looking that's
like that you want to know when this
graph intersects with two in order to
solve the first bit right so just
visually if you think about if at two
four and five he is my my to life so if
you're aware of expecting my solutions
okay now I can't just look at that like
this is too icky to the aerosol visually
with precision anyway so I'm going to
think about this branch which is y
equals 3x minus 5 and I'll just look at
the other branch which is y equals minus
3x plus 5 just everything with negatives
and your once I solve each of those it
will give me the two days ok so really
quickly minus 2x plus 5 equals 2 minus
3x equals Bironas 3x equals 1 yes now if
that look if I had to pick this does
that matter what you expect and for
solutions dr. bit to the left and 5 F X
1 and 2/3 that's one thumbs up we've
discreetly crush the other one 3x minus
5 equals to tell you what to do so you
bring a 500 stepping and yet identified
agree so this is to the third again yes
and I believe exceeded the synergy there
right okay so now that I know where this
should point our migration
onto my graph so this one here is one
this one here is 7/3 okay so now ready
to use that to solve this this is where
the absolute value collides with two
this is where the absolute value is
beneath - so I have a look at my web
let's see looking for being part here
that is beneath the two line if I would
change the direction of you equally and
say where did he ask you value above two
and I don't want the V I want the
outside parts no so the V is between one
and seven third not on the outsides of
one and 7/3
so therefore I can say for this final
question here it's between one and seven
military business and you always have to
drive on you won't always be asked so
that's sometimes that's your answer but
frequently they'll say represent that on
a number line so then conveniently I've
already drawn by the border right there
okay so I would say we saw boundaries
included so I'm going to go field circle
feeling circle and then average other
ones so it doesn't say for that Indians
that I'm doing if they would say you
know I mean they'll say look for a verb
is always a verb right if the verb is
simply sold now you tell me the X values
that satisfy this there they are
orbiting will then say soul and heads
plot the solution on a number line on
the back on another line that's what it
looks like um in the internet the value
question like even at if you're trying
do you so much oh my god it's not that
big of an employee time do you have
drawn test it if it is Impala size do
you have to test it okay
so you've got a bit of an issue there
because the trager's no because if I
hung this is my solution for my equality
how are you going to test different
number of nothing in this amount are you
looking you can't actually put
everything in a test it out with a
finite number solution
TV on yes you can but the grass tells
you everything you need to know it told
you you don't have to test because these
are the two points in section I mean I
think as I go because the variable not
common sense if there's a variable on
the other side and yes because what
happened is as an example suppose I now
solve do you have not yet anyway if I
add something to this question like a
tent value of 3x months fine let's solve
with them equal to 4x plus 1 okay now
again I'm going to appeal to the glass I
don't think that what I'm most resistant
look like well I've got a y-intercept of
5 from the original graph I guess that's
about 1 what are the rest of the
equation tell you in here Margaret it's
a certain state line right and
importantly it is steeper than this line
right now because it's steeper or
destroyed roughly with them the included
steep as you see that this red line is
never going to intersect with this
branch over here
never happens out there just going to go
further and further apart they do come
closer together but at what point
slender stops okay now the reason why
this becomes together for testing if you
cannot grasp your sword straight
indicators right if you were straight
indicators you will write at some point
for n times 1 equals 3x minus 5 because
this is the this in this case right and
then you get a solution of this well
let's let's just go ahead and do it
subtract 3x website gives you X subtract
1 for another time it gives you negative
6 but this is more it's clearly not a
solution right can you tell me why well
number one it should wait that's like
one right it's like I did nothing
happening over there right secondly the
reason why this is in the solution is
because this only exists in a certain
case when when is the absolute value of
3x minus 5 equal to 3x minus 5 and the
answer is to the right of x equals of
our exes
right so look you see how these are
contradictory right so you can do you
test this and it won't you won't work
with let's just put it back in it of the
left-hand side is going to be the
absolute value of minus 18 minus 5 which
is 22 23
the right-hand side is going to be
negative 24 plus 1 which unsurprisingly
is exactly the opposite but exactly the
opposite is we tried the wrong case in a
place where done images from a movie DMC
therefore x equals minus 6 in my
solution yeah or it just isn't out yet
correct either of those would be fun
they both say it's a very silly but then
what about darling even though you know
it's a solution I show unity like this
one that I just solve is asking what the
upper branch all right yes you see is
what you do is you go and do your
suppose I can raise this from the board
right if I do my cases blindly like if I
if I don't take this for another I just
like okay as if it did it's frequently
do this they write one line here they
don't tell me why they doing it they
just like I know I've got to be
something like that
and then they do the other one over on
the other side and minus three X plus
five and then it's also sold sold sold
and then they get an answer right if
you've got something over here
and something over there and you have
explained where these pictures for
coming from you haven't given some kind
of domain restriction you don't have a
picture that tells you what is what then
how do you know which one is which how
do you know which one is this mission
which is getting valid and the solution
which is not good valid a son you must
test every time serving in epigraph is
you have to prove or even craft them
your grass substitute as your test
because I've been looking I could say
frog the graph this is not a solution in
fact I would do that
I would say step I would say from the
ground I don't even need to look for a
solution on this is irrelevant
it will never give me one that's why the
graph even if it takes time to draw it
even if it's like a basic graph which is
not my whole measure
stuff it's good enough to be seen
there's only one place I need to test
for I'll get straight to that equation
well completely different variable
dispenser anyway if you have a variable
and this is why I did it first time in
all cases where do you have a variable
ordering another variable
I would graph okay you're in extension
once you just change this media or wrap
your head around something like this as
an extension wants to do you should be
able to leave that ground like that so
that's what I would do if you're asking
what I do because it's just faster fun